[Music]
my name is sarah and i am an art
conservator at center art studio i'm
going to walk you through how my team
and i restore a 19th century italian
marble sculpture and its alabaster base
so it's been broken it's been previously
repaired it came to us broken again this
work of art is comprised of four
separate
pieces that includes the marble bust its
sockle base
and a pedestal which is in two parts a
top and a column
we're going to clean the bust the sockle
base and the pedestal components all
separately
we start out on all of the pieces by
using a surfactant detergent diluted in
distilled water and spray it onto the
marble and the alabaster we want to use
what we need to properly clean a piece
but we never want to do anything that's
too harsh
this surfactant is very gentle and it
lifts the dirt off the surface
kind of breaks the surface tension
between the dirt and the surface and
allows us to
wipe or swab away the accumulated
surface dirt and debris
[Music]
the column is quite dirty and this is
because a pedestal column sits on the
floor
and the dirt from the floor from
people's shoes it all gets brought up
onto that surface
we also use surfactant gels particularly
in areas that might be a little bit more
stubborn to clean
when restoring something so old you have
to be mindful of the age of the piece
so we never want to remove all of the
dirt out of all the recesses and
completely remove the patina that's
built up on an item
of age because that would end up looking
incorrect and inappropriate
so the top of the pedestal and the
sockle base that the bust sits directly
on have both been previously repaired
twice with the same types of glue we
need to
entirely remove all of this old adhesive
that's not functional it's yellowing
it's not good for the marble to have on
its surface so we want to make sure we
get all of it off so we are using a
combination
of scalpels
this is also a time where you have to be
very careful because marble is very
susceptible and alabaster is very very
susceptible to scratching so when you're
using those very sharp tools you want to
make sure
that you are only scraping off the glue
and you're not accidentally
nicking the surrounding surface area
[Music]
we use a number of visual aids to help
us in the conservation process
one tool that's very helpful
is a small spotlight and this is a very
direct targeted light that allows us to
very clearly see the area that we are
working on
we also use a black light which is very
useful because the
uv light allows us to see
imperfections and residues on the
surface that are not visible to the
regular human eye
to attach the broken items back together
we are going to use a special
conservation epoxy
it is called ebotec this is a two-part
epoxy that you combine together when you
first mix it it can be quite liquidy so
we allow it to sit for a little bit of
time just to develop a little bit more
of a viscous quality
we are going to
permanently attach the
marble to the sockle base we're going to
reuse the original model rod once we
have it at the right depth we put the
pin in the hole of the bust and we use
our epoxy pour that into the recess
then we put the base on the marble check
it for alignment front to back and left
to right and
allow that to cure for a little while
to ensure that the repair of the top of
the pedestal is extremely strong we are
going to pin the pieces in addition to
epoxying them we are going to take a
stainless steel rod stainless steel
is desirable because it's not going to
rust or change over time
we mark on the outside of the piece
where we're going to drill
holes to take the pins
and we are using
our ancient drill press
once we have the holes
we have the pins
we
then can use our epoxy
to
attach the two pieces back together
[Music]
we are going to fill the cracks in the
sculpture with plaster
we are applying the plaster with
small metal tools we tend to
err on the side of over-filling because
it's very easy to remove the plastic
material
the plaster cures quickly so you want to
make sure that you're getting enough on
while it's still workable
once we've filled the cracks and we've
allowed the plaster to
fully
dry we are going to sand particularly
the alabaster base
which had a large crack throughout the
entire thing we are going to sand that
down with different grits of sandpaper
[Music]
in painting
a marble sculpture is really the same
technique that we use for
any other sculpture or a painting
we are using our standard gamblin
conservation colors
we mix them up to get the right color in
this instance because the marble and the
alabaster are sort of translucent
it makes our job a little trickier
because we're trying to replicate
translucency on an opaque fill
in this instance you really can't mix
one color and apply it to the whole fill
you have to do thin washes of different
colors to mimic the texture
and the veining of the stone material
we are going to polish the alabaster
base and we use a very large polishing
wheel for this and we use polishing
compound applied to the wheel
and that polishing compound comes in a
variety of grits we use very fine ones
in this instance so it doesn't damage
the alabaster
the final step of the conservation is to
wax each piece of the sculpture
so we are using a very very fine micro
crystalline wax and we apply this
over the whole surface of each one of
the pieces allow it to dry for just a
little bit and then buff it off very
gently with soft cloths
this wax is important it
not only
makes the stone
look good visually it also serves as a
protective layer between the stone
and the elements
once all of the components are complete
in their own right we do a final
assembly and this is how the piece will
be ultimately displayed at the client's
home
we are very satisfied with how the whole
piece came out we know the client loves
this piece and has had it broken for
a long time we think she's going to be
very happy